[Music]
in celebrity lawsuit news oh [ __ ]
submitted by gnarly brow oh [ __ ] gnarly
bro
a man is suing one of Paltrow for
allegedly doing a hit-and-run during a
skiing accident oh my god if a celebrity
hit me oh wait so rich on the slopes
i hit-and-run on the slopes or with the
car no cuz that happens all the time my
everything is hard not to do a
hit-and-run
you just sliding down a hill how does he
know it was her though so what she was
bundled up so this is what happened this
happened in Utah Park City Utah oh this
is for Sundance this happened back in
2016 so nice resistant the victim here
is this doctor so he says like he
already rich yeah well this whole this
Deer Valley ski resort apparently is
like for like the rich oh oh yes yeah so
then um he he said that he broke four
ribs and suffered a brain injury after
she crashed into him from behind when
they were skiing down the mountain and
then so now he's asking for 3.1 million
dollars in damages same Wow
so his lawyer is saying that she run
into him and so he was like face down
and that when her ski instructor was
like that was accompany her
that he berated the doctor saying like
do you just took up when a peltro or no
Gwyneth Paltrow you got knocked off [ __ ]
out my clinic Paltrow he wasn't quite
apologized way it's pretty much like
would oh wait you can't be in the way of
pepper potts yeah all right man is gonna
kill you yeah yeah so then the doctors
like yeah a lot of people who ski up
there they don't know what they're doing
but yes the risk you run I mean that
even happens at Snow Summit or like any
ski resort like that just happens you
know I receive my multiple cut it into
I've been the beginner that smashed and
straight up knocked over children and
grandparents
and I've been the person that knew how
to snowboard and get t-boned you're like
you know how like you could go up the
hill where this is the slope and if
people could just kind of sit there and
watch and wait yeah
I've been chilling there just talking
and then come out down comes this
beginner you can't [ __ ] stop and he
tries to go like on our side thinking
that the hills gonna stop him and he
just runs us all over that should happen
but if I have four broken ribs and a
brain aneurysm or something and you're
secure I'm and your celebrity I'm going
nuts I'm getting rich what it's come
back so this dr. Asian I'll slip in a
[ __ ] puddle in Walmart and you don't
know man I'm telling you man right when
that accident happened I'm telling you
once you forearm crawl game over dude no
what I've seen though I've seen someone
get paralyzed
that shit's crazy oh my god I didn't see
the actual accident
but I've seen the the snowball snow
mobile app that go all the way up and
put him in that yellow stretcher and
then get pulled down because the pyramid
was creamy she's paralyzed okay and I
think that person's little brothers like
he's paralyzed I'm like maybe he was
freaking out like oh god he's paralyzed
I don't know I was like I'm done I'm
done snowboarding for the day yeah yeah
see see see Muriel loves snowboarding
right and she's like go snowboarding go
snow Bernie I'm like no she goes it's
not that bad I was like listen yeah
y'all die I've seen so many people eat
[ __ ] my cousin dislocated shoulder my
other friend broke it broke his
collarbone yeah we and she last time she
went through she sprained her knee I'm
like dude I [ __ ] my hobby is Muay Thai
I'm not spraining my [ __ ] knees like
that's the last thing I need you just
don't go on the Black Diamond that's it
no I [ __ ] mine up my I [ __ ] up my
tailbone on a bunny slope well that's
just your learning that's his beginner
growing pains so what's a banana run
once I mean when you do like normal [ __ ]
when you just it's like it's nothing
it's like riding no and Anna
oh yeah it's pretty easy now yeah don't
do no jumps and and you know just I'm
addicted easy [ __ ] I'm safe and warm in
my own house
I like the disc which is probably a lot
more dangerous but let yeah
about skis and snowboards is that my
legs are consistently attached to it
mm-hmm
yeah bail out what's the bail out
because you're supposed to be a state on
it what it toys and like your body twist
the other way oh I should socks dude
yeah how in you lads this way and I get
that like you down [ __ ] man and you
can't that's why I'm telling me you can
Christ [ __ ] up my knees you have to
listen you have to [ __ ] hear me [ __ ]
about it for the rest of your life are
you ready for that you could take this
[ __ ] what like if you get sick I'm
not gonna take care of ya I'm saying it
was right that's the extreme no not for
me dang can't relate at all I've never
done any sport activities that's crazy
I've only done this led1 I've never
actually had like it's never wait we
don't a snowboarding trip what did you
do I had to take care of Isaac that day
and then we got there the next day when
you guys you guys were gonna do the
skiing and stuff that day but then you
moved it up a day so we met the next JK
trip we got a snow you mean you're not
gonna snowboard snowboard
oh really I thought you did because you
had a snowboard
I used to snowboard I just don't like it
that's how I know I don't like because
I've tried it so many times I've done it
so many times I had my love doing on the
daughter road tour that way and if they
got snow today they came back I really
wanna like see tyka and I bundled up
like a fox like he looks like a [ __ ]
we did what do we say he looks like mr.
Mishler man
Inuit but I'm like I want it to be like
fresh snow and you just toss him in
there he disappears in like six feet of
snow below like Kazakh Mongolian baby
with the front if he gets all red in
here it looks like you're low like
Kazakh baby okay yeah so this doctor
here he said that he suffered memory
problems as a result of his brain injury
and that at times she felt mentally ill
and that he couldn't function in the
months following the incident
um he's making this [ __ ] up though it's
not fair but Gwen
drones team is saying like this guy it
took him three years to file a lawsuit
because no one would take his case
because in reality he's the one that
bumped into Weymouth Paltrow is how do
they prove that what her team is yeah
how are you gonna prove either one of
this yeah
three years later I want to see the CCTV
where he goes straight for good and POW
so she's like oh [ __ ] the [ __ ] calls
line the [ __ ] out of him and knocks him
down and he's like oh he openly admitted
that he didn't really see her he's
taking it on the countless somebody else
said that was going at Paltrow yeah and
it could be another Gwyneth Paltrow last
night on the celebrity yeah I mean if
it's a rich resort I guarantee you
there's a lot of rich white ladies that
look like that especially if you got
goggles on turtleneck goggles blonde
hair it's [ __ ] go there and just lay
in the snow until someone hits me 69
where does he practice I ain't trying to
code it doesn't practice that medicine
anymore thank God yeah so that's why he
needs to that lawsuit oh that's not like
a mother [ __ ] sorry I don't know it
just sounds a little shady you're do you
guys remember after all that rain the
snow caps on the [ __ ] mountains
I was driving those like damn that
should look frosty as [ __ ] it's
beautiful Big Bear and look like Utah
that was pretty crazy gorgeous I ain't
like my whole life I've never seen that
that's just like five feet of snow it
was beautiful I never seen that [ __ ] let
me put Tyga in the back and I snowboard
on the bunny slope
oh he falls backwards you know they got
little snowboards and [ __ ] for kids
right place - that is not a speak yet
I've seen a baby in video where he's
just it just saw there they push them
like tigers H or at least exercise
because these even uh left or right yet
mmm yeah how about that how about that
[ __ ] baby in China that right
what do you call it the [ __ ] air
thing what about the maybe in China if I
can cook in a wok and feed his family
doing that baby was tired
hmm with the baby in China that was ice
skating doing wrong that [ __ ] we
can't do with the Chinese babies dude
that's what I'm saying dude they're
motor functions Chinese you should be
able to do that what's that [ __ ]
douche mopey oh that all the vlogger
kids ride the t-rex no hoverboard
hoverboard oh you never we did Jay King
knows the [ __ ] baby that rides on
board
Oh Chinese baby riding a hoverboard oh
there we go
the chubby whoa wait how old is that
baby like one two but like with the
cigarette smoking around his body is
like 30
you saw that [ __ ] baby the [ __ ]
Chinese baby put a trash bag on the
[ __ ] trash can and then push that
[ __ ] down I was like whoa I never did
that [ __ ] huh genius has little Chinese
baby you know you put like a plastic
shopping bag in the trash can to line it
yeah you know like you put it in and you
just like like you what is it do how do
you do it
do you skinny and then put it around
then spur it out I go like this I just
put it around the rim and I push the
center down so what he did was he put it
and then that's like a still air bubble
on top then he pushes it down and then
it and then it climbs that genius that's
what I've never seen anyone do that
before you neither a lot of people have
it whoa put it in first and then I put
on the room and then I spread it like a
bottle oh I just put it in then if it's
a little I mean it's the same way people
it is the same way people put put on
these yeah well that's not what you're
talking about
no oh what are you talking about heap
it's like a grocery bag he put it like
an air bubble in so like it's still
floating like a bubble on top and then
he pushes it in and then it sinks in
okay yeah oh okay yeah I see mm-hmm you
know what a trashcan trashcan no it's
because he's using a shopping bag no
it's a noob regular shopping bag
everyone use possibly I'll just take
your word for this video I don't know
why I blew my brain away I don't know I
can't wait till Tycho's motor skills get
a little bit better so that he can start
hitting I want to just put him in
everything I want so you know we're
gonna train our guns with this
on the skateboard his heads are way too
big for the huddlecam breaking that [ __ ]
that time seems we he's already in sup
in gymnastics and swimming it's like
fake ass gymnastics but is it just like
kids rolling around and [ __ ] bumping
try to teach them directions like
everyone runs in this way so the other
kid goes the string starts going up sit
there like no no no so then they try to
run the same but it's just chaos I want
to talk to this kid though it's chaos I
don't throw that kid around period I
probably don't have to you around he
probably would I throw him in a foam pit
he was crying no I don't like it but
when I jump in with him in the foam pit
then he really likes it but now the
second time you was in a foam pit you
really liked it that's why you gotta
throw them in things
[Music]
[Music]